The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I think
it's a good idea
to review where we
were because we're
kind of in the middle
of a discussion.
We're actually on part three.
And probably, there will
be four parts all together
of our discussion of
homogeneous expansion.
So I have a few slides to just
review where we were last time.
We were building a mathematical
model of our homogeneously
expanding universe.
And we modeled it as
a finite-sized sphere
where we promised
that in the end
we will take the limit as
the size of that sphere
goes to infinity and
fills all the space.
But it started with some
initial maximum, R max i, i
for initial.
We arranged for it to have
a uniform density, rho.
We started at a
time called t sub i.
There were some initial
maximum radius, R max i.
And we also set this up to
exhibit Hubble expansion.
And we're going to
try to calculate
how it evolves from there.
But we're going to start
it Hubble expanding.
And Hubble expanding
means that we're
starting with every particle
having an initial velocity
which is a constant, H sub i,
the initial value of the Hubble
expansion rate,
times the vector r.
That is, the vector that goes
from the origin to the point
where the particle is located.
And that corresponds
to Hubble expansion
centered on the
center of our sphere.
So these are our
initial conditions.
We just put them in
by hand because we
think they form a good model for
what our universe looks like.
And then, the laws of
evolution should take over
to govern what's
going to happen later.
And since we haven't
studied general relativity,
we'll be using
Newton's law of gravity
to discover how it behaves.
But I promised you
at the beginning
that we will, in fact, get
exactly the same equation
that we would have gotten had
we used general relativity.
And we'll talk later
today, probably,
about why that's the case.
So this is the initial setup.
Any questions about
the initial setup?
OK, then we derived
a lot of equations.
And everything really
follows from the statement
at the top here, which is
understanding what Newton tells
us about the gravitational
field of a spherical shell.
We could always think
of our solid sphere
as being made up of shells.
So if we know how
a shell behaves,
we know all we need to know.
And Newton told us.
He told us that inside a
spherical shell, the effect
of gravity, which I'm
describing in terms
of the gravitational
acceleration vector, little g,
inside a shell, the
gravitational field is exactly
0.
The force is coming from all
different parts of the shell,
pulling outward,
cancel each other.
And the net force on any object
anywhere inside the shell
is exactly 0.
Outside, the entire
shell acts exactly
as if it were a single
point mass located
at the origin with the
same total mass, m.
So incredibly simple.
It's hard to believe it's
so simple, but it is.
By the way, if you use
Gauss's law of gravity,
it becomes very obvious
that those statements
are the right statements.
Newton know about
Gauss's law of gravity,
so Newton derived
those statements
by brute force
integration, which
is more of a tour de force.
But something Newton was
capable of doing it, and he did.
To describe how the
system is going to evolve,
moving onward, we introduce
something that's a little bit
complicated, a function r, which
is a function of two variables,
r sub i and t.
And r represents
the radius at time t
of the shell that was
initially at radius r sub i.
And our goal here is not just
to keep track of the particle
on the outside,
which is for example,
what Ryden does in her textbook.
Ryden assumes that
everything stays homogeneous.
And then if you follow what
happens to the outer edge,
you know everything.
But we're not going to
make that assumption.
We're going to conclude
that it remains homogeneous,
but we're going to derive it.
Which means that we need to know
the motion of every particle
inside the sphere
to be able to tell
if it's going to
stay homogeneous.
And that's why we're introducing
this more general description
where r is a
function of r sub i.
So that function of
the extra variable
will tell us how every particle
moves as the system evolves.
We know that we're going to
maintain spherical symmetry
because we start with
spherical symmetry
and the force law respects
spherical symmetry.
So we're building that
in from the beginning.
We're not allowing things to
depend on angular variables
theta or phi.
But assuming spherical
symmetry, motion just
is described entirely by
giving the r-coordinate
of each particle.
And this function r of r i
t does that-- exactly that.
Then, we said that
at a given radius,
this description
about shells tells us
that the shells that
are outside that radius
don't do anything
at a given radius.
But the shells that are
inside act like a point mass,
as if it was all at the origin.
So to understand how a given
shell is going to evolve,
all we really need to
know is the total mass
inside that shell.
And that's given
by M of r sub i,
the mass inside the
shell at radius r sub i.
And that's just the
volume of the shell
initially times the
initial mass density.
As these shells move, the
total mass inside a shell
will remain exactly
the same as it
was as long as there's
no crossings of shells.
Now, the shell crossing
issue is hard to talk about.
But in the end, it
just doesn't happen
so you don't need
to worry about it.
But the argument was
that initially we
know the shells are moving
apart from each other
because we built in
this Hubble expansion
where everything is moving
away from everything else.
So if shells are
ever going to cross,
they're not going to
cross immediately.
It will take some time for
these velocities to reverse,
and the shells that were moving
apart to move together and hit.
So there's unambiguously
at least a period of time
where there are no
shell crossings.
And we could write
down the equations
that describe the motion
during this period
where there are no
shell crossings.
Now, if there was going
to be a shell crossing,
the equations that
we're writing down
would have to hold
right up until the time
of that first crossing.
Because as long as
there's no crossings,
our equations are valid.
Which means that if there was
going to be a shell crossing,
the equations we're writing
down had better show it.
Because the equations
that we're writing down
have to be valid right
up until the instant
of any possible shell crossing.
And what we're going to
find is that the equations
are going to lead to just
homogeneous evolution
where there are no
shell crossings.
And therefore, that's
the conclusion.
If there were going to
be any shell crossings,
these equations would
have to show it.
They don't show it, so there
are no shell crossings.
So it's a complicated
paragraph, but the bottom line
is simple- we can
ignore shell crossings.
And that means that the total
mass inside of any shell
will remain exactly
constant with time
given by its initial value.
And this formula is
the initial value.
And therefore, it
holds at all time.
Any questions about that?
Any questions about the
shell crossing issue?
OK, good.
So whoops, sorry about that.
So M of r sub i is the mass
inside the shell at radius r
sub i.
And then we can write down-- now
we use Newton's law of gravity
directly.
We can write down
the acceleration
of a given particle in
terms of its radius r
and its initial radius r sub i.
Its initial radius determines
how much mass is inside.
M of r sub i is
independent of time.
But the actual radius it's
at determines how far away
it is, or describes how far
away it is from the origin.
And that's the 1 over r squared
that appears in the force law.
So we have the time dependent r
in the denominator and the time
independent initial r sub i
that appears in the numerator.
And it's all proportional
to a unit vector r
hat pulling everything
radially inward
because of the
minus sign in front.
So gravity is pulling
everything inward,
which is what we'd expect.
So this formula is
the key formula.
It's a vector
formula, but we know
that all the motion is radial.
So all we really
have to keep track
of is the radius as
a function of time.
So we can turn
this vector formula
into a formula for
little r itself.
Just the radius number,
the radial coordinate.
And we get r double dot is minus
4 pi over 3 G r sub i cubed rho
sub i, taking the
formula for M of ri
from the line above
divided by r squared.
And the r in this formula--
I didn't write the arguments,
but it means this
function r, which
is a function of two
arguments, r sub i and t.
So this differential equation
now governs our entire system
and tells us everything
we need to know
or everything we can know
about the actual dynamics.
But to solve a
differential equation
of that sort, a second
order differential equation,
we need initial conditions.
And we already described the
initial conditions in words.
Now we have to just figure out
what those initial conditions
are saying about r and r dot.
And the answer is
straightforward.
We argued it last time.
The initial conditions
are that r at time t
sub i is just r sub i.
That was really the definition
of r sub i in the first place.
And r dot is just H
sub i times v coming
from the formula we had
for the initial velocities.
So these three equations,
the two initial conditions
and the differential
equation, lead in principle
to a mathematical solution
that's completely unique
and determined by
those equations.
And our goal now is
just to figure out
what that solution looks like.
And we discovered a
marvelous scaling property.
That is, instead
of talking about r,
we divided r by r sub i and
defined a new function, which
we initially called u.
Initially, thinking
of it as a function
of these two variables.
We can write down
new equations for u.
And those equations
end up not having
any r sub i's in them at all.
And once we realized
that, we realized
we don't need to call
it u of r sub i and t.
It's really just
a function of t.
And at that point, we
renamed it because we also
realized that it actually
is our old friend the scale
factor, a of t.
So a of t is just r of r sub
i and t divided by r sub i.
And then the reason
this is a scale
factor is seen most clearly from
that equation, which is really
this equation just rearranged.
The physical distance of
a particle from the origin
is equal to the scale
factor times r sub i
where r sub i plays the role
of the coordinate distance.
r sub i is a time-independent
measure indicating
which shell you're
talking about.
So the equations for a then
are the equations for u,
which are the equations for
r just divided by r sub i.
And we can write down
what those equations are.
We have a differential
equation for a
and two initial
conditions where r
sub i has dropped
out all together.
The differential equation
is given immediately
from the one we had up
here, but we could also we
write it in terms
of what rho of t is.
I didn't write the
equation here because I
guess I was running out of room.
But we also figured out
how rho of t behaves.
And it behaves in
the obvious way.
As the space
expands, the density
just goes down as the volume.
And the volume grows like a
cubed, the cube of the scale
factor, because volume's
proportional to radius cubed.
So rho of t is just rho sub
i divided by a of t cubed.
And putting that in, we
can go from that equation
to this equation.
And this equation makes
no reference anymore
to the initial time.
It's just an equation for what
deceleration you see, what
value of a double dot
you see, as a function
of the mass density
and a itself.
OK, any questions about any
of those differential equation
manipulations?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the homework, it
says that this equation is not
entirely general.
We can't use it in all cases.
Whereas, the other version
that we get from the energy
conservation is completely OK?
PROFESSOR: That is correct, yes.
AUDIENCE: It says it in
there, but why is that?
PROFESSOR: Why is it true?
Well, as long as you have only
non-relativistic matter, which
is what we're
talking about here,
both of these-- this
equation is golden
and so is the equation
we're about to talk
about the derivation of,
the conservation of energy
equation.
So as long as we have the
context in which we derived it,
it's completely valid.
But on the homework
set, we're talking
about more general cases.
We gave a different formula
for the scale factor,
which corresponds to a
different situation in terms
of the underlying materials
that are building that universe.
And where the change
occurs is when
one introduces a
nonzero pressure.
This gas of particles
that we're talking about
is just non-relativistic
particles
moving with the
Hubble expansion.
There's no internal velocity
which generates a pressure.
And it's pressure that
makes a difference.
This formula assume
zero pressure.
We will learn later
how to correct it
when there's a nonzero pressure.
And the other formula
doesn't depend on pressure,
so it's valid whether
there's pressure or not.
But at the moment, we have
no real way of knowing that.
We'll talk later
about why that's true.
Other questions?
No.
OK, great.
OK, one more slide here,
not too much on it.
At the end of the last
class, we took the equation
that I just wrote on
the previous slide.
I just copied it to this slide,
the equation for a double dot,
written in terms of the
initial mass density.
And discovered that it
can be integrated once
to produce a kind of a
conservation of energy
equation.
And all you do is
you start with this,
write it by putting everything
on one side of the equation,
a double dot plus 4 pi over 3 G
rho i over a squared equals 0.
And then, multiply the
whole equation by a dot.
And a dot is called
an integrating factor.
It turns the expression
into a total derivative.
So once you write
it this way, it
is equivalent to dE dt
equals 0, where e is just
defined to be this
quantity that would
have better as a
triple equal sign.
e is just defined
to be that quantity.
And if you then write
down what dE dt means,
it means exactly that.
So it's the same equation.
So given our second
order equation,
we can write down a
first order equation,
which is that E is
equal to a constant.
And we commented last time that
the physical interpretation
of E is-- I'm not
sure what to say.
There are multiple physical
interpretations of E
is probably what I want to say.
And one physical
interpretation is
if you multiply by
the right factors,
it does describe the actual
energy of a test particle
just on the boundary of our
sphere, on the outer boundary.
It doesn't really describe
directly the total energy
of a particle inside that
sphere because calculating
the potential energy of a
particle inside the sphere
is more complicated.
And it doesn't give
you the simple answer.
So it doesn't really describe
particles on the inside,
except you could argue
that if you-- talking
about a particle on the inside,
the particles outside of it
don't matter.
And you pretend
they're not there.
And then it does
describe the energy.
That is, you could
think of any particle
as being on the
outside of the sphere
and ignore what's outside it.
But that's extra sentences
that you have to put in.
On the homework, you
will also discover
that for this finite-sized
Newtonian sphere,
there's certainly a
well-defined Newtonian
expression for the total
energy of the sphere.
And that's also
proportional to this E.
So by multiplying it
by different constant,
you can turn it into the
total energy of the sphere.
So it's actually
related to energy
and it's definitely conserved.
Those are the important
statements to takeaway.
And that's where we
left off last time.
And we'll pick up from
there now pretty much
on the blackboard for
the rest of lecture.
Are there any further
questions about these slides?
OK.
In that case, we will go on.
The first thing I want to do is
to take the same conservation
law that we have up
there and rewrite it
in a way that's
more conventional.
And perhaps, more useful.
But certainly,
more conventional.
We started with knowing that a
quantity called E is conserved.
And it's equal to 1/2 a dot
squared minus 4 pi over 3
G rho i over a.
OK, then we also
know that rho of t
is equal to rho sub i divided
by a cubed of t, which just says
that matter thins out with
the volume which grows
as the cube of the scale factor.
And that can be used to
manipulate this equation.
For reasons that will
become clearer in a minute,
I'm just going to manipulate
this equation by multiplying it
by 2 over a squared.
Just because this will
get me the equation
I'm trying to get to.
So if I multiply the left-hand
side by 2 over a squared,
I have to multiply the
right-hand side by 2
over a squared.
The 2 cancels the half.
The first term becomes
a dot over a squared.
And you might remember the a dot
over a is the Hubble expansion
rate, so it has some
physical significance.
And then, minus the 2 turns the
4 pi over 3 into 8 pi over 3.
And the a squared multiplies
the a to make an a cubed.
And then here, we have
rho i over a cubed, which
in fact is just the
current value of rho.
So we can rewrite this as a
dot over a squared minus 8 pi
over 3 G rho.
No a's anymore on
the right-hand side.
Well, on a's anymore
in this term.
OK, now the convention
that brings our notation
into contact with the
rest of the world.
Nobody talks about
E, by the way.
That's just my convention.
But to make contact
with the rest
of the world, the rest
of the world talks
about a number called
little k, lowercase k.
And it connects to our notation
by being equal to minus 2E
divided by c squared.
And with that connection, we
can write our conservation law
in what is the standard
way of writing it,
at least in many textbooks.
And that's it.
So I put a box around it.
And this equation was first
derived by Alexander Friedmann
using general
relativity in 1922.
And it is, therefore, usually
called the Friedmann equation.
Alexander Friedmann, by the
way, was a Russian meteorologist
by profession.
But as a meteorologist,
he knew a lot
about differential equations.
And when general relativity came
out, he got interested in it
and was the first person to
derive using general relativity
the equations that described
an expanding universe.
And he wrote two famous
papers-- now famous papers--
in 1922 and 1923.
One of them talking about
the system of equations
where k is positive
and another talking
about where it's negative.
I forget which
order they were in.
But they correspond to
open and closed universes,
which we'll talk about
more in a few minutes.
Now, I just should remind you
to have our equations together.
We also had the all-important
equation for a double dot.
And as I was just describing
an answer to a question,
we don't know yet how
to generalize this
to other kinds of matter besides
the non non-relativistic dust
that we just derived them for.
They're certainly both correct
for our non-relativistic dust.
But when we try to generalize
them, what we'll find
is that the top equation
will remain true exactly
for any kind of matter, while
the bottom equation assumes
that pressure equals 0.
Now, the standard terminology
is to call the top equation
the Friedmann equation.
In fact, both of
these equations,
with this one including the
pressure term that we don't
have yet, appeared in
Friedmann's original papers.
So I usually refer to
these two equations
as the Friedmann
equations-- plural.
But many textbooks refer to just
the top one as the Friedmann
equation and don't give a
name to that equation, which
is also OK if you want.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Didn't we
get the top equation
from the bottom equation?
PROFESSOR: We did.
That's right.
So how does that jive?
The answer is-- and we'll
be coming to this later.
But the answer is that when
we got the top equation
from the bottom equation,
we used that equation.
And this equation
will no longer hold
when there's a
significant pressure.
And in fact, when we derive
it later-- I forget what order
we'll do things in.
But we'll make sure that
all three of these equations
are consistent when
we include pressure.
The reason the top
equation changes
if you include pressure--
may not be obvious.
But if I tell you
why it happens,
it will become obvious.
The top equation looks like
it's just how things thin out.
Like a cubed.
But rho is the
total mass density.
And relativistically, it's
equivalent to the energy
density.
If you just multiply
by c squared,
that becomes the energy
density by the E equals
mc squared equality.
So it's a question of
how much energy there
is inside this sphere or box.
And if you imagine
a box changing size,
if it's filled with a gas
with a positive pressure,
as that box changes
size, the pressure
does work on the boundary.
If you think of it as a piston.
And if we have a positive
pressure and a gas expands,
it loses energy.
And relativistically, that
means it has to also lose mass.
The total mass inside the
box does not remain constant
as it expands, which
is the idea that we
use when we derive that
rho i over a cubed.
So rho i over a cubed
is the right behavior
for the total mass
density or energy
density for a zero pressure gas.
But when you include
pressure and take
into account relativity, that's
not the right formula anymore.
AUDIENCE: The top one, it
just cancels out somehow?
PROFESSOR: Well, the pressure
ends up canceling out,
so that this ends
up still being true
and this ends up
being different.
And we'll see later
how it happens.
I just want to indicate where
the changes are going to be.
We'll see what the changes
are when we get there.
AUDIENCE: What happened
to the third factor
of a in the second equation?
PROFESSOR: There's a
factor of a missing, sorry.
Yes, thank you very much.
It's important to get
the equations right.
That wasn't
Friedmann's equation.
That was Alan's equation.
Now it's Friedmann's equation.
He got it right.
OK, any other errors or
questions to bring up?
OK.
Now is probably a good time to
talk about the question of why
we were so fortunate to discover
that the Friedmann equation
that we derived agrees exactly
with general relativity.
There is a simple reason for it.
I don't think it's
an accident at all.
The reason for it,
as I understand it,
is that we assume
from the beginning--
and we would be assuming
this whether we're
talking about the
Newtonian calculation
or the corresponding general
relativity calculation.
We assume from the
beginning that we
are modeling a completely
homogeneous system, where
every part of it is identical
to every other part.
And once you assume
that homogeneity,
it means that if you know
what happens in a little box,
a meter by a meter
by a meter say.
If you know what
happens in a little box,
you know what happens
everywhere because you assume
that what happens everywhere
is exactly the same as what's
happening in that box.
So that implies
that if Newton is
right for what
happens in the box,
Newton has to be
right for what's
happening in the universe.
And we do expect
Newtonian physics
to work on small scales,
scales of a meter,
and small velocities.
The Hubble expansion of
a meter is negligible.
So we expect Newton to give
us a proper description of how
the system is behaving
on small scales.
And the assumption
of homogeneity
guarantees that if you
understand the small scales,
you also understand
the large scales.
So I think we are guaranteed
that this had better give us
the same results as
general relativity or else
Newtonian physics is
not the proper limit
of general relativity.
But it is.
We would not accept
general relativity
if it did not give
Newtonian physics
for small scales
and low velocities.
So we expect to get the
same answer as Gr and we do.
This is exactly
what Gr would give.
And this is exactly what Gr
would give also for the case
where there's no pressure--
the case we're doing.
OK, any questions about that?
OK, next item.
I would like to
say a couple words
about the units in
which we're going
to define these quantities.
So far, in our
mathematical model,
r and r sub i are distances.
And therefore, they're
measured in whatever units
you're using to
measure distances.
And I'll pretend
we're using SI units.
So I'll say meters.
We could use light
years, or whatever.
It doesn't really matter.
But they're both measured
in ordinary distance units.
And earlier when we talked
about scale factors and things,
I told you that many
books do it this way.
Think of both the
co-moving coordinates
and the physical distances
as being measured
in meters and the scale
factor being dimensionless.
But I told you I don't
like to do it that way
because I think it's
clearer to recognize
that these co-moving
coordinates don't have
any real relationship
to actual distances.
At least not as time changes.
So for me, it's better
to have a different unit
to describe the co-moving
coordinate systems.
So I would like to
introduce that here.
And all I need to do really is
say that let the unit of r sub
i be called a notch.
Now, we already
called it a meter,
but that doesn't really
mean that a meter is
the same as a notch.
Because when we
called it a meter,
we were not really
taking into account
the fact that it's only
a meter at time t sub i.
So another way of
describing this definition,
which might not sound like we're
trying to redefine the meter,
is to say that the statement r
sub i equals 5 notches, which
is the kind of statement I'm
going to make now because I'm
only going to talk about r
sub i measured in notches.
When I say r sub i
is 5 notches, that's
equivalent to saying that the
particle labeled by r sub i
equals 5-- 5 notches-- was
at 5 meters from the origin
at time t sub i.
So giving the value of a
co-moving coordinate in notches
tells you exactly
what distance it
was from the origin
at time t sub i.
Now, the reason why I don't
use this to just say, well,
why don't we call it
meters, is that we're now
going to forget about t sub i.
If you look at
equations we have,
t sub i no longer
appears in any of them.
t sub i was just our
way of getting started.
And we could have started
at any time we wanted.
And once we have
these equations,
we can talk about times
earlier than t sub
i, times later than t sub i.
And there's nothing special
about t sub i anymore.
But r sub i we're going to
keep as our permanent label
for every shell, which means
for every particle there will be
a value of r sub i attached
to that particle which will be
maintained as the
system evolves.
And it will be clearly
playing the role
of what we've called the
co-moving coordinate.
And therefore, we will
want to keep r sub i
and we'll want to call
its unit something.
And I'm just saying I'm
going to call them notches.
You can call them
meters if you want,
but I'm going to
call them notches.
So using this language, I'm not
changing any of the equations
that we wrote.
So we will still have r being
equal to a of t times r sub i.
But now, r will be
measured in meters.
a of t I will think of
as meters per notch.
And r sub i will me
measured in notches.
And the scale factor a of t
will be playing the same role
it played ever since we
introduced the word scale
factor.
It just means that when
the scale factor doubles,
all distances in our
model double exactly.
Now that we have the sort
of new system of units,
I just want to work out
the units of an object
where the units are
not all obvious.
What are the units of
this thing that we've
defined that we called k,
which is related to this thing
that we defined that was called
E, where E was not really
an energy?
But we can work out what k is.
I'm using square brackets
to mean units of.
k can be thought of as being
defined by this equation.
Or in any case, this
equation certainly
must be dimensionally
consistent because we derived
it and you didn't point out
that I made any mistakes,
so I must not have.
So the units of kc
squared over a squared
should be the same as the
units of a dot squared
over a squared.
And if I multiply through
to write units of k--
to relate them to a dot,
we get the units of k
have to be the same
as the units of 1/c
squared times a dot squared.
The a squareds in
the denominator
here just cancel each other.
So the units of k has to be
the same as the units of 1/c
squared a dot squared.
And we know what they are.
The units of 1/c squared
is second squared
per meter squared.
Meter per second
squared, but upside down.
That's the 1/c squared factor.
And a dot is meters per notch
per second because of the dot.
So meters per notch would be a.
a dot would have
an extra second.
And the whole thing gets
squared because it's
a dot squared here.
And you see then that
the meter squares cancel.
The second squareds cancel.
And we just get the peculiar
answer 1 over a notch squared.
Now, there's probably not a
lot of intuition behind that.
But what it clearly
does say is that we
can make k change its
numerical value by changing
our value for the notch.
And that's important to know.
And it's a clear consequence
of what we just did.
So now we can talk about
different conventions
that people use for
defining the notch.
And hence, k, which are
clearly related to each other
we've now learned.
So first of all, in the
construction that we just
did-- starting out with our
sphere, and letting it grow,
and defining the maximum sphere
as r max comma i and so on.
In that construction, our
initial value of t-- excuse
me, our initial value
of a, a of ti, was one.
And the way we
first did it where
all lengths were
measured in meters.
And with our new definition that
r sub i is measured in notches
so that a is meters
per notch, it
means that in the system
we just had, a of t sub
i was 1 meter per notch.
And since we
already did this, we
don't really want to change it.
But I point out that t sub i,
if you look at our equations,
survives in only one place,
which is in this equation.
It has disappeared from
every other equation
we're going to be keeping.
So we are perfectly safe in just
forgetting about this equation.
Or if we want to
remember about it,
we could just say, well, yeah,
t sub i had some significance.
It was the time at which
the scale factor happened
to have been equal to
1 meters per notch.
But otherwise, it
has no importance.
There's a different time
when the scale factor was
10 meters per notch, or
1 light year per notch.
So since t sub i is of
no relevance whatever,
we can safely forget
the above equation.
Or we could think of it as
the definition of t sub i,
where we don't care
anything else about t sub i.
So it was just some
symbol that was
used in some
earlier calculation.
So we now just have a
scale factor a of t.
And we can talk about how
we might normalize it.
And there are basically
two important conventions
that are in use in textbooks.
Some textbooks, which include
Barbara Ryden's textbook
that we're using,
define a of t to be
equal to 1, which I will call
1 meter per not much today.
So a of t is just defined to be
1 today as a common notation.
It's notation that
Barbara Ryden uses.
And that makes a notch
equal to a meter today.
There's another
common convention,
which is to recognize that since
k has units 1 over notches,
we can make k any value we
want without changing any
of the physics, just changing
our definition of the notch,
which is up for grabs.
Nobody has yet
defined the notch.
We're defining it now.
So we can choose the
definition of a notch
to make the value of
k something simple.
And the obvious choice for
the simplest real number
that you could imagine
that's not 0 is 1.
So we could choose
the definition
of the notch to
make k equal to 1.
Except that we can't
change the sign of k.
The sign of k makes important
differences in this equation.
And we don't want to make the
definition of a notch negative
or imaginary, I
guess, is what you
need to change the sign of k.
So as long as
notches are real, we
can only change positive k's
to different positive k's
and negative k's to different
values of negative k.
So the convention would be
that when k is not equal to 0--
it can be 0 as a special case.
But when k is not equal
to 0, define the notch
so that k is equal
to plus or minus 1.
I would say that
this convention is
more common than that
convention of the books
that I've read in my
lifetime, but both conventions
are in use.
And one sees from this
dimensional relationship
that one can certainly
choose a notch
to make k if it's nonzero
have any value you
want of the same sign.
And that means you can
always make k plus or minus
1 if it's not 0.
The books that use this as their
convention, generally speaking,
leave the notch undefined
when k equals 0.
Undefined means arbitrary.
And there's no problem with
that because k and the notch
never really appear in
final physical quantities.
The notch always
was just your choice
of how to write down your
co-moving map of what
the universe looks like.
OK, any questions about these
funny issues involving units?
OK, good.
The next thing I
want to do now is
to start talking about
solutions to this equation.
And I guess I'll leave the
equation there and start
on the new blackboard.
OK, I'm going to rewrite
the equation almost the way
it was written on the top there.
In fact, exactly as it
was written on top there.
I'm going to
rewrite the equation
as E equals 1/2 a dot squared
minus 4 pi over 3 G rho sub i
over a.
And the reason I'm writing it
in this way rather than any
of the other six or seven
ways that we've written it,
is that this way the only
time-varying thing is a itself.
And if we want to talk
about what the differential
equation tells us about
the time variation of a,
it helps a lot if we're writing
an equation where a of t
is the only thing
that varies with time.
And this is at least
one way of doing that.
So in particular, I used
rho sub i rather than rho.
So the behavior of this
equation might very well
depend on the sign of E.
And we'll see that it does.
And if we think it might
depend on the sign of E,
we realize from the
beginning that E
could be positive,
negative, or 0.
There are those three cases.
So those are the cases
we want to look at.
E can be positive,
negative, or 0.
So we'll take them
one at a time.
It will help to make things
completely obvious to rewrite
this as an equation
for a dot squared.
I'll multiply by 2.
And write this as
equation a dot squared
is equal to 2E plus 8 pi
over 3 G rho sub i over a.
8 pi instead of 4 pi
because we multiplied by 2.
And we notice that this term,
proportional to rho sub i
over a, is
unambiguously positive.
We're not going to have
any negative mass densities
in our problem.
There's no way that can happen.
And a is always positive.
So the right term is positive.
a dot squared had
better be positive
because it's the
square of something.
E could, in principle,
have either sign.
And we'll talk about both
cases, or the 0 case.
But if we start with the
case where E is positive,
just to consider these
three cases one at a time.
So suppose E is greater than 0.
And remind you that E
and k had opposite signs.
So that would imply
that k was negative.
So if we start by considering
the k negative case or the E
positive case, then we see that
we have a positive number here
and a positive number there.
So they will add up to always
give us a positive number.
a dot squared will
always be positive.
And it will just mean that
a dot will be positive.
Square root of a positive
number is a positive number.
At least it's only the positive
square root that matters here.
So a will just keep growing
forever in this case.
a dot squared will
never fall below 2E.
So it will be a lower
bound to a dot squared.
And that means there will
always be a minimum expansion
rate that the
universe will have.
So in this case, a
increases forever.
And that's called
an open universe.
And it's one of the
three possibilities
that we're going to
be investigating here.
Next case is E
less than 0, which
is the more common notation of
k means k is greater than 0.
In this case, if you think of
E as an energy, which it really
is, it means we have
less than 0 energy.
Which means that we basically
have a bound system.
And the equation tells us that
it acts like a bound system.
We don't have to rely
on that intuition,
but that is the right intuition.
The equation up there tells
us that if E is negative,
the total right-hand side
had better be positive
because the left-hand side is
positive and the left-hand side
cannot go negative.
But this term is going to
get smaller and smaller
as a increases.
And as this term gets
smaller and smaller,
it runs the risk of no
longer outweighing this term
and giving possibly
a negative answer.
And what has to happen is a
cannot get any bigger than
the value it would have where
the right-hand side would
vanish.
So a continues to grow
because a dot is positive.
This gets smaller and
smaller until this term
equals that term in magnitude.
And then, a dot goes to 0.
What happens next
is not completely
obvious from this
equation, but it
means that we have an
expanding universe that's
reached a maximum
size and then stopped.
Then, what is actually
obvious is from this equation
is that it will
start to collapse.
So this case corresponds
to a universe that
reaches a maximum size and then
turns around and collapses.
So a has a maximum value.
And we can read off
from that equation what
it is, a max is
just the value that
makes the right-hand
side of that equation 0,
which is minus 4 pi G
rho sub i divided by 3E.
And remember, E is
negative for this case,
so this is a positive number.
So a has some positive
maximum value.
Reaches that value, and then
turns around and collapses.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I don't know
if you said this already,
but since a dot squared is
equal to some quantity, when you
solve for a dot, you can have
positive and negative solution.
Why do we discount
the negative solution?
PROFESSOR: OK,
very good question.
The question if
you didn't hear it
is, why do we discount
the negative solution
when we have an equation
for a dot squared?
Couldn't a dot be
positive or negative?
And the answer is it
certainly could be either.
And both solutions
exist as valid solutions
to these equations.
But we started out with
an initial condition
that a dot was positive.
Our initial value
of a dot was H i.
And once it's positive,
it can't change sign
according to that equation.
Except by going
through 0, which is
what we're talking about now.
But it will only change
sign when it goes through 0.
So it reaches a maximum
value, then it does collapse.
And in the collapsing
phase, that same equation,
a dot squared equals
the right-hand side,
holds where it would be
the negative solution that
describes the collapsing phase.
So the verbal description
of what's happening here
is that the universe
reaches a maximum size
and then collapses.
And it collapses all the way
to a equals 0 in this model.
And that's often
called the Big Crunch
for lack of a better word.
The Big Crunch being
the collapsing form that
corresponds to the
Big Bang, which
is the instant which
all this starts.
And this was called
an open universe.
As you could
probably guess, this
is called a closed universe.
OK.
And now finally, we want
to consider a case where
E is not positive
and not negative.
The case that we're
left with is E equals 0.
And that's called
the critical case.
So the critical value
for E is E is equal to 0.
And that means that k
is equal to 0 as well.
It implies k equals 0.
And notice that this
is a special case.
E is a real number.
It can be positive,
negative, and 0 is just
a particular value on the
borderline between those two.
For the people who are in the
habit of rescaling notches
so that k is always
plus 1, minus 1, or 0,
it makes it sound like there are
three totally distinct cases.
But that's only because
of the rescaling
that those people are doing.
If you keep track of E as your
variable, which you certainly
can, you do see that
the flat case, E equals
0-- the critical
case-- is really
just the borderline
of the other two.
And it's therefore, arbitrarily
close to both of the other two.
It really is where they meet.
But working out the equations,
we have in this case
a dot over a squared is
equal to 8 pi over 3 G rho.
And in general, it's minus
kc squared over a squared.
But we're now considering
the case where that vanishes.
And that means we
have a unique value
for rho in terms
of a dot over a.
And at this point, it's
worth reminding ourselves
that a dot over a is just
H. So this is H squared.
So for this critical
case, the case
that's just on the borderline
between being open and closed--
and we'll be calling it flat.
For this critical case, we
have a definite relationship
between rho and H.
So rho has to equal
what we call the
critical density, which
you get by just
solving that equation.
And it's 3H squared over 8 pi G.
And we see, therefore, that
rho being equal to rho c
is this dividing line
between open and closed.
And if you think back about
the signs of what we had,
what you'll see is
that rho bigger rho
c is what corresponds
to a closed universe.
Rho less than rho c
is what corresponds
to an open universe.
And rho equals rho
c can be called
either a critical
universe or we'll
be calling it a flat universe.
And the meaning of the word
"flat" will be motivated later.
For now, these words--
open, closed, and flat--
refer to the time
evolution of the universe.
We'll see later that
it's also connected
to the geometry of the universe,
but we're not there yet.
Then the word "flat"
will make some sense.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do we know there's
not some very large entity,
like some cluster of
black holes or something
that renders all of this not
applicable to our universe?
PROFESSOR: OK.
The question is, how
do we know there's not
some humongous perturbation,
some huge collection
of black holes that
renders this all
inapplicable to our universe?
The answer is that it
works for our universe.
That is, observationally
we can test these things
in a number of ways.
Tests include calculations
of the production
of the light chemical
elements in the Big Bang.
Tests include making predictions
for what the cosmic background
radiation should
look like in detail.
And those tests work
extraordinarily well.
So that's why we
believe the picture.
But you're right,
we don't have really
direct confirmation
of most of this.
And if there was some
giant conglomeration
of mass out there someplace, it
might not have been found yet.
But so far, this
picture works very well.
That's all I can say.
And there really is
quite a bit of evidence.
We'll maybe talk
more about it later.
Any other questions?
OK.
So having understood
the importance
of this critical
density, it might
be nice to know what the
value for the critical density
for our universe is.
And we can calculate it because
it just depends on the Hubble
expansion rate, an the
Hubble expansion rate
has been measured.
So if we try to put
in numbers, it's
useful to write the present
value of the Hubble expansion
rate, as it's often
written, as 100 times h sub
0 kilometers per
second per megaparsec.
So this defines h sub
0, little h sub 0.
And I think the main advantage
of using this notation
is that you don't have to keep
writing kilometers per second
per megaparsec which gets to
be a real pain to keep writing.
So little h sub 0 is just
a dimensionless number
that defines the
Hubble expansion rate.
And it does then allow you
to write other formulas
in simple ways.
Numerically, Newton's
constant you can look up.
It's 6.672 times
10 to the minus 8
centimeter cubed per
gram per second squared.
And when you put these equations
together, all you need to know
is G and H squared to
know what rho critical is.
You find that rho critical can
be written initially for any H0
as 1.88 h0 squared
coming from the h squared
in the original formula times
10 to the minus 29 grams
per centimeter cubed.
And note the whopping smallness
of that 10 to the minus 29.
The mass density of
our universe is, as far
as we know, equal to
this critical density.
We know it's equal to
within about a half
of a percent or so.
And h0 is near 1.
h0, according to
Planck, is 0.67--
according to the
Planck satellite
measurement of the
Hubble parameter
And if you put
that into here, you
get the critical density
is about 8.4 times 10
to the minus 30 grams
per centimeter cubed.
And that is equivalent to about
5 protons per cubic meter.
So I've written
the answer in terms
of grams per cubic
centimeter because
to me that's a very
natural unit for density
because it's the
density of water.
We're saying that the average
density of the universe is only
about 10 to the minus
29 quantity 8.410.
The average density of the
universe is only about 10
to the minus 29 times
the density of water.
So it's an unbelievably empty
universe that we're living in.
It's hard to believe the
universe is that empty,
but there are large spaces
between the galaxies
that we look at.
So the universe is
incredibly empty.
And in fact, this is a
vastly better vacuum.
An average part of the universe
is a vastly better vacuum
than can be made on
Earth by any machinery
that we have access to.
So the best vacuum is empty
space, just middle of nowhere.
And it's vastly better
than what we can actually
produce on Earth.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I see you
used protons here,
5 protons per cubic medium.
So is this density corresponding
to density of baryonic matter,
or all types of matter?
PROFESSOR: This is actually
all types of matters,
even though I'm using my
proton as a meter stick.
But it is the total mass
density of the universe that's
very close to the
critical value.
And I was just about
to say something
about what the total
mass is made up of.
Cosmologists define-- this
was certainly mentioned
in my first lecture-- a
Greek letter capital Omega
to mean the actual mass
density of the universe divided
by this critical density.
So omega equals 1 in
this language corresponds
to a flat universe at
this critical point.
Omega bigger than 1 corresponds
to a closed universe.
And omega less
than 1 corresponds
to an open universe.
And today, we know that
omega is equal to 1
to an accuracy of about
a half of a percent.
To a very good accuracy we
know omega is very close to 1.
It's made up of
different contributions.
And these tend to vary with
time-- as the best measurements
tend to vary with
time by a few percent.
But omega matter-- and
here I mean visible
plus dark matter--
is roughly about 0.3.
And most of the universe
today, as we mentioned earlier,
the universe today is pretty
much dark energy-dominated.
So omega dark energy
is about equal to 0.70.
And omega total is
pretty close to 1.
Plus or minus about
a half of a percent.
So one of the
implications here is
that we've been assuming
in our calculation so far
that we're talking about nothing
but non-relativistic matter.
That's actually only about
30% of the actual matter
in the current universe.
So I did say this
is the beginning.
The current universe today
does not obey the equations
that we've written
down very accurately.
It's pretty far off.
But the equations
that we wrote down
are pretty accurate
for the history
of our universe from a
period of about 50,000 years
after the Big Bang up
to about 9 billion years
after the Big Bang.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Before dark
energy was discovered,
did they think omega
was [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
At least many people did.
Before dark energy
was discovered,
there was a controversy
in the community
over what we thought omega was.
Those of us who had
faith in inflation
believed that omega
would be 1 because that's
what inflation predicts.
Astronomers who just had
faith in observations
believed that omega
was 0.2 or 0.3
because that's what they saw.
And the truth ended
up being somewhat
in between in the
sense that omega
total we now all agree
is very close to 1
as inflation predicts.
But it's still true that the
stuff that the astronomers saw
at this earlier time did
only add up to 0.2 or 0.3.
So they correctly estimated
what they were looking at
and they had no way of
knowing that there was also
this dark energy component
until it was finally
discovered in 1998.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If we don't know what
dark energy is, observationally
how have we been
able to measure that?
PROFESSOR: How do we
measure it so accurately
if we don't know
what it is, right?
Right.
Well, the answer
is while we're not
sure what it is, we
actually do think
we know a lot of its properties.
And essentially, almost
all properties that
are relevant to cosmology.
We just don't know what's
sort of like inside.
So we know it creates
repulsive gravity.
We know how much repulsive
gravity it creates.
And we also know to
reasonable accuracy
how the dark energy
has been evolving
with time, which is
really that it's not
been evolving with time.
And that determines
what its pressure is.
It determines, in
fact-- to not evolve
with time we'll see later
requires the pressure
to be equal to the negative
of the energy density.
Pressure is related to how
energies change with time, as I
mentioned a few minutes
ago in a different context.
If you have a box that expands
and there's a pressure,
the pressure does dp
dv work on the box.
And you can tell how much
the energy in the box
should change for
a given pressure.
And we'll do this
more carefully later,
but to have the energy
not change at all
requires a pressure, which
is the negative of the energy
density.
So we know how much acceleration
the dark energy causes.
We know to reasonable
accuracy and we
assume it's true
that the pressure is
equal to minus the
energy density.
And that's all you need to know
to calculate how much of it
you need to account for
that much acceleration.
And that's how it's done.
Any other questions?
OK next thing we want to
do is to actually solve
this equation for
the easiest case.
We'll solve it in general
later, but the easiest case
to solve it is the case
of the critical case.
We only have a few
minutes, but it only
takes a few minutes to solve
the equation for this case.
It should be over here.
So for the critical case,
it's the case E is equal to 0.
And therefore, we
just have a dot
squared is equal to a
constant divided by a.
And it won't really
matter for us
right now what this constant is.
So I don't even have
to keep track of it.
I'll just write it
as const, C-O-N-S-T.
And I'll take the square
root of this equation
because it's easier
to know what a dot is
than to know what a is.
Easier to make use of
knowing what a dot is.
So I can rewrite that equation
as a dot, which I'll now
write as da dt, to be a little
more explicit about what we're
talking about, is equal to a
constant over a to the 1/2.
So this now is the k
equals 0 evolution.
So this is just the
same Friedmann equation
rewritten for the
special case k equals 0.
And now I'm just
going to perform
the amazingly complicated
manipulation of multiplying
both sides of the
equation by a to the half.
So we have a to the half.
I'm also going to
multiply by dt.
So a to the half da will be
equal to a constant times dt.
And now we can just
integrate both sides
as an indefinite integral.
And integrating both sides
as an indefinite integral,
the left-hand side
becomes-- go back over here.
2/3 a to the 3/2 is
equal to a constant times
t plus an arbitrary other
constant of integration.
This is the most
general equation,
which when differentiated
gives you this.
And now, this
equation can be solved
to tell us what a is
as a function of t.
But before I do that, I'm going
to say something about c prime
here.
c prime is allowed
by the integration.
But remember that when we
defined our scale of t,
we just started at
some arbitrary time,
ti, which we didn't
even specify.
So there's no
particular significance
to the origin of
time in the equations
that we've written so far.
So we're perfectly free to
shift the origin of time
by just redefining our clocks.
Cosmic time,
remember, is defined
in a way which makes it
uniform throughout the universe
by our construction.
But we haven't said anything yet
about how to start cosmic time.
But now, we have a
good way to start it.
In this model,
there is going to be
a time at which a
is going to go to 0.
No matter what we
choose for c prime here,
there will be some t which will
make the right-hand side 0.
And therefore, a 0.
And that's the instant
of the Big Bang.
That's when everything starts.
a never gets smaller than 0.
So it's very natural
to take that to be
defined to be the 0 of time.
So that's what
we're going to do.
So we're going to define t
equals 0 to be when a of t
equals 0.
That's just a
choice of the origin
of time, which you're
certainly allowed
to do without contradicting
anything else that we've said.
And that means we're just
setting c prime equal to 0.
So that when that's 0, that's 0.
So this implies
c prime equals 0.
And that then
implies-- we could take
the 2/3 power of this equation.
And I told you we don't really
care what that constant is.
So therefore, we
don't really care
about what that constant is.
What we get is that a is
equal to some constant,
not necessarily related
to any of the constants
we've said so far.
Although, you can
calculate how it is.
But some constant times
t to the 2/3 power.
Or equivalently,
you could just write
a is proportional to
t to the 2/3, which
has the same content.
Now, you might think
you'd want to know
what the constant of
proportionality is.
But remember, the constant
of proportionality
just depends on the
definition of the notch.
If you want to define the
notch so that a is equal to 1
today, then you would
care what the constant is.
If you're willing to just leave
the definition of the notch
arbitrary, then you don't
care what the constant is.
And that's the case that
I'll be doing, actually.
I will not define
a to be 1 today.
The definition of the
notch is just arbitrary
as far as the equations
that I'll be writing.
And therefore, it will
be sufficient to know
that a is just proportional
to t to the 2/3
for the flat universe case,
for the critical density case.
And that's where
we'll stop today.
And this actually pretty
really covers everything
through lecture notes three,
which is the same material that
will be covered on
the quiz next week.
[INAUDIBLE] does not
seem to have shown up,
but we'll assume that probably
the review session will
be next Monday night at 7:30.
I will check it out and
get back to you by email.